Now, let's dive into actually going hands-on and creating
our camera cuts in our sequence.
Now, if you haven't already, go into your Content Browser.
And under the Sequence 105.0.0 folder,
go ahead and create a new folder
and name it whatever you'd like.
But in this case, we'll do SEQ underscore EX, for example.
And then from within that Content Browser,
or if you want to create it from the main toolbar,
go ahead and create your level sequence by right-clicking
and under the Cinematics dropdown,
we will create a level sequence.
And you can name it SEQ 105 underscore EX, for example,
or whatever is easiest for you.
All right, and if you haven't already,
in your Content Browser, make sure that you have the Sequence
105 start map open, which will be in the Sequence 105
folder under Maps.
Go ahead and open that up, and we'll get started.
So I'm going to fly up to this little platform
that we have up here.
And this is where we're going to create our first animation.
Now, if you have one of the existing sequences in there,
not a problem.
Go ahead and just delete it.
Again, that won't delete the sequence.
That'll just delete the actor in the level.
All right, so the story that I want to build here
is that, let's say that I'm playing in game
and I trip a cut scene.
And in that, I've got this special character
that runs from this platform, jumps down,
comes galloping across the landscape,
and comes to my location to give me a quest.
So that's the story of the narrative that I'm building.
And I'm going to do that in three shots.
So for this one, we're actually
just going to set up the first shot,
and then we'll cover how you can create the other two.
All right, so I'm going to go down to my Content Drawer.
And in my Sequence Example, I'm going
to open up that sequence that we just created.
Now, mine just says Example here.
You may have the other one.
Whichever one you created, just go ahead and double click.
Let's open it, and now we have our blank sequence.
OK, so the first thing that I'll do
is actually just stage our actor in this scene.
So I'm going to go back to my Content Browser,
and I'm going to go to the Stacobot folder.
And I believe what I'm looking for is under Characters, Bot,
and it should be, find it here, there it is.
Under our Meshes, we're going to use the skm underscore bot.
And you'll notice the little purple light pink bar,
and it says Skeletal Mesh.
This is what we want.
Let's go ahead and just drag them into the scene,
put them anywhere is fine.
I'm going to jump back to my sequence,
and what I'm going to do is going to right click,
and I'm going to do this Actor to Sequence.
And you'll notice that because I have the bot selected
in the world, the Add SKM Bot is at the top.
Now, if the actor wasn't selected,
I've deselected it now, and I right click Actor to Sequence,
you'll notice that I'd have to go in and search from my bar.
Click our actor, make this easy on ourselves,
right click, Actor to Sequence, SKM Bot.
And there we go, so now we have our actor in the sequence.
Now, we are also going to convert this over
to a replaceable.
As we covered in one of the earlier videos,
this is a new type of actor reference
that we can have inside of our sequence,
meaning that we can replace this character at runtime,
but for the purposes of building our sequence,
this is the example we can work with.
I'll go ahead and just do Convert Selected Bindings
to Replaceable Actor, and notice the icon changes,
and we are good to go.
All right, now the first thing that we're gonna do
is animate this character running off
of our little platform here.
So I'll just go ahead and move him back,
and I'll put on my rotation.
Now, if you don't want snapping, just go up to your main,
kind of the little bar up here in the upper right,
and you can turn off snapping.
So I'll turn off the rotation,
and I'll turn off my grid snap.
So now I can do just some fine adjustments,
and that's perfect.
So we'll make sure he's lined up, ready to go.
And now what I'm gonna do underneath my SKM bot,
under Animations, I'm gonna click our little plus button,
and I'm just gonna type in run,
and that should give us our A bot run.
We'll go ahead and add this animation,
and you'll see if I scrub this,
we get one of our animation loops.
So let's go ahead and just drag this animation out to,
I don't know, something around like maybe 135.
And you'll notice as we do it,
we get these little ticks here
showing that the animation is looping,
which is perfect, that's exactly what we want.
All right, so the next step is that we need to
kind of move this character
to make it look like he's actually running.
Now, we're going to do this completely by hand,
there are other methods for this,
but we're just gonna go super basic here.
So under my SKM bot, underneath Transform,
I'm gonna click the little plus button in the middle,
which is add key to the current time.
And then I'll go ahead and add a keyframe
and record the position information of our character.
And then you can see the little square that was created,
that is a reference to our key, our timeline.
All right, now before I move the character,
if you remember, we have this option
to create keyframes when a property changes.
So we're gonna have that activated
just to make it easier on ourselves.
I'll drag this out to our 135,
and what I'm gonna do is activate my move,
and I'm gonna move our character
right to the end of the platform.
Now you can see that it automatically
created a new keyframe,
we can see that displayed in our viewport as well.
And if I go back to our start and play,
see the character moving,
and it's not bad, this is pretty good.
One of the thing you may have noticed
is it looks like he's kind of skating on ice at the start
and the reason for that is our keyframe interpolation.
For this shot, I want the character
to look like he's already midway in running,
and we just happen to open the frame,
open the camera as he's running past.
So to do that, I'm just going to select
my first keyframe, right click on it,
and change our key interpolation to linear.
Now if we play, you'll see he kind of looks
like he's already starting to run,
and I'd say that's pretty good.
All right, we could do the same thing here on this one
if we wanted to, change it to linear,
go back, and now we can see him running,
and you see he kind of goes and stops.
I think that works well for us right now.
All right, perfect, so we have our animation,
our run, and we have our transform.
The next thing that we need to do
is we need to have him jump through the air and fall.
So the first thing I want to do
is actually expand my timeline out here,
because you notice that we stop at 150,
and roughly the, I think we've got what,
15 keyframes is not enough for the animation,
so let's go ahead and extend our timeline out.
So to do that, a couple ways,
we could increase our view range,
or I can simply go down here and type in,
I'll do something like 200, it'll move our timeline,
and I'm gonna click this little red arrow,
which will then set the out point now to 200.
Give us ourselves a little bit more time.
I'm gonna move my play head back to 135,
and we're going to add another animation.
Go back down to our animation track,
click our plus, and we are going to search for jump.
We're looking for the Abot Run Jump.
So we'll go ahead and add that,
and now you'll see that as he runs,
he'll then go to our jump animation, which is perfect,
and I'll expand this out just a little bit.
And then let's go ahead and just add the third animation,
which is going to be our falling animation.
So same thing, click our little plus,
there it is at the top, fall,
but you can search for fall, Abot Fall.
And so now you'll see he runs, jumps,
and then goes into his falling animation, all right?
And let me go over here real fast
and just show you something that's happening.
So as you see, he jumps, and then he snaps to our fall,
which is not what we want.
So I can select my fall animation
and actually drag this back,
and you'll notice that it starts to blend.
And what's gonna happen here is
this animation is going to blend the keyframes,
so the skeletal position of all of our joints,
between the jump and the fall.
So now we should get something that looks a little smoother.
We do have a little hiccup there.
We'll see as we animate it, what's going on,
but this should get us within that range.
In fact, actually, let's go ahead and fix that now.
So I'm just gonna quickly undo this
just to get back to my frames.
And the reason why we have this little pop
is you'll notice that the jump animation is only so long.
So let's constrain the keyframe there,
move our fall back here, and then blend.
So this should make it a little easier, and there we go.
Now we've got our smooth transition.
So real quick, just to recap what happened there,
our jump animation was really only meant to happen once,
but because we had extended this animation
to include a second loop,
it just produced an interesting and weird look.
So we just clipped it back
to the actual animation timeline and blended,
and now we should be good to go.
All right, so at this juncture,
we just need to animate the rest of his movement.
So we do have our auto keyframe on,
and I'm gonna go to about the apex here
of this little jump here,
and let's just move him up into the air.
That looks about pretty good.
Now, if you'll notice, something happened here.
So this is the keyframes,
and what's gonna happen is he's gonna run,
but he's going vertical.
And the reason for that
is because our auto keyframe is turned on,
it's only going to add a key when the property changes.
So if I expand our transform out,
and in particular, our location,
you'll notice that when I manually created a keyframe,
it created a keyframe for all of our properties.
So location, all the channels, rotation and scale.
But when we made our adjustment at 135,
only the X and Y position changed, his Z did not.
So when we did our jump, we of course changed Z,
and it says, oh, I'm gonna add a keyframe.
So we can do this several different ways,
but this will be the cleanest and most efficient.
So I'm gonna go back to our 135,
and I'm gonna go to my Z channel
and just create a new keyframe just for that channel.
Now, if we go back, we were going,
let's go ahead and move him upwards as if he's jumping.
And you'll notice now he goes through his cycle runs
and then jumps, just perfect.
Then let's go to the end of our fall here
and just move him down to something that feels right.
He'll be off camera, so not super concerned.
All right.
Now, if you've worked with animation before,
you'll know that this jump right here,
because again, we have all of our keyframes set linear,
is not gonna feel supernatural.
The reason for that is just gonna be very linear
in nature, but really what we want is
this bot to kind of come up in the air
and slow and then accelerate down.
So to do that, I'm just gonna select the keyframes here,
right click, and we can change it to cubic auto,
cubic smart auto, whatever works fine.
Let's just do smart auto for now.
And we'll go back, let's hit play,
and let's see what our character does.
Runs, jumps, and falls.
Not too bad.
I will say that the fall speed is probably
a little too slow for my liking.
So I'll go back to our keyframes here
and just maybe move him down a little bit more.
Back to our start, let's hit play
and let's watch him run and jump.
That feels much better.
All right, we'll go ahead and just save this out.
And now our animation and our first part
of our sequence is done.